730 niños han muerto de hambre en
centros de nutrición en somalia según
unicef la falta de alimentos se suma a
otras complicaciones como las epidemias
de sarampión cólera o malaria la onu
líderes internacionales temen que
regrese una temporada de hambruna como
la de 2011 cuando por lo menos 250 mil
personas murieron la mayoría eran niños
maastricht la desnutrición ha alcanzado
un nivel sin precedentes tenemos un
millón y medio de niños en desnutrición
esto es casi la mitad de los niños
menores de 5 años es probable que tengan
desnutrición aguda y de ellos 345.000
necesitarán tratamiento para la
desnutrición aguda severa
este llamado de alerta por parte del
fondo de naciones unidas para la
infancia llega tan sólo un día después
de que la misma onu advirtiera por
segunda vez en una década que somalia
está al borde de la hambruna y mientras
la región del cuerno de áfrica entra en
su quinta temporada de lluvias fallidas
en situaciones regulares se esperaría
que la región aporte el 70 por ciento de
la precipitación anual sin embargo con
las largas temporadas de sequía que
están acabando con el ganado y la
agricultura se espera que la cifra de
los 80 millones de personas que sufren
de inseguridad alimentaria aumente para
fin de año la hambruna hasta la vuelta
de la esquina y seremos testigos de la
muerte de niños a una escala
inimaginable en los últimos meses de
2022 si no actuamos rápido 30 mil
personas han estado llegando y
moviéndose entre campos de desplazados
internos cada semana la mayoría han
caminado hasta 10 días en busca de
comida y agua en el llamado de alerta de
naciones unidas- hizo que la
financiación para el país africano
aumentará en las últimas semanas de la
petición de la organización
internacional de 1.460 millones de
dólares ya se ha recogido un 67%